Big X.
Good morning, Rick. Thank you for joining.
Morning, Evan.
Hey, good morning, Anthony.
We can't hear you. You're mute.
Morning, Anthony.
Oh, sorry about that. I sent this over to Andrew too. He might join as well, but I know he might he might also be wrapped up into something. No big deal.
Sure.
So, how you doing?
Good, Anthony, you tell.
Fantastic.
Good.
How have you been?
But I think the other...
No, go ahead.
I was just asking how have you been, Anthony?
Good.
Sophie completed the week 1 onboarding in three days. That's a good thing. She's shown so far that she's not scared to get in there and start to learn. So it's good. It's really good.
Yes.
Good to hear from you. Thank you.
That's exactly what we'll talk about today.
What she has done so far, and you know, as per SpiderNet, you know, how the plan looks like. I thank you, Andre, Andre, for joining in.
Hello.
The other team members, I believe they're attending other calls at the same time. We have multiple calls running at the same time, so uncertain. They'll be able to join, you know, timely, but they may jump in in between as soon as their call ends.
So, Tim, are we good to start?
I'm good.
All right, thank you. Rick, before we start, anything from your end?
No, I'm good. Thank you, Andrew, for all the help the other day for getting the access set up and everything.
Yeah.
Yeah, no problem. Sorry, I missed that meeting invite. I should have got everything whitelisted now for you guys. It looks like some stuff was going to junk.
No, it.
Yeah, and Anthony, I'll double-check in my end as well, so what all...
Participants need to be here. Yeah, but you are here in this meeting. I see that.
So do we need any more people from your side attending this call? Go ahead. Okay.
Nah, we're good. We're good on our end.
All right, thank you.
Just a moment.
Let me share my screen and it must be there on your screens in a few seconds.
Yeah.
Rick, can you confirm? Is it there?
I see it here.
Yeah, Pritam.
Excuse me for my dry cough. Thank you.
All right, Team, thank you. So this is for the week one, June 1st through 5. Although, I mean, we know that she had just initially onboarded with SpiderNet Technical Consulting. So she has not, you know, started to take on tasks as yet, but
We'll see.
So, you know the drill agenda when previously when this slide was shown to you. So, we have executive summary, performance review, ITBD service offerings, team GPS, AI by design, holiday schedule, and pay forward with spider net.
Highlights, so onboarding in VOM handover has been completed, and Sophie has gone through the onboarding process document for her initial week. I was checking with her yesterday, so you have a document which is called onboarding process document that represents, you know, shares days one to two and three to five.
Right, so she was going through that that document, so she understands what she what is expected out of her in the first five days. Hi, Vishal, thank you for joining in.
Please, please go ahead.
I just, yeah, I've just started sharing my screen, so you have not missed anything major.
So this is the first slide. Thank you.
I just, I just came to say hi to Anthony. Good.
Oh, hey. Appreciate that, Vishal.
It.
Yeah.
Okay, thank you.
So she has, Sophia's got access to the following tools and she has started working with a team, SpiderNet Technical Consulting, LLC. So Anthony, Andrew, so these are the tools that she got access as of now. So 365, MS Teams, Outlook.
Ohh, that means emails, auto task, cassia, do.
And.
Just a moment.
I mean, my screen froze for a moment, just a moment.
Let me re-share that.
Sorry for this technique glitch and I hope this is visible back to you.
Exceed here.
Okay.
So she is getting familiar with the tool set and daily triage process at you end and planned activities. This is what I'm going to show, you know, on separate files. So implement 30, 60, 90 day plan, what we incorporate at ITBD end.
I think I had given you a glance at it previously when Sam was on board with this account, but we have prepared this for Sophie. Her CDG plan with Spider Net and other planned activities support Sophie, which will be our continued practice.
to address any challenges, if there are any. Low lights, as, yeah, please go ahead.
Uh, Gagan.
Sorry, I appreciate, you know, you are coming with this presentation, although I know Sophie has not really started working on this account. And just want to hear out from Anthony. I mean, do you want to go through the deck or if you have any other question for us or any, you know, any feedback or anything else we need?
Okay.
Yeah.
with Sophie's account, anything from your side, Anthony. I saw your email, the message you sent me this morning. I'll take it with the accounting team. So allow me some time. I will be on that. Anything else from your side? We can go to the deck, no problem at all. But in case of anything you want to share with us.
Sure.
Am I sharing my screen for now? Yeah.
No, I...
I appreciate. So we have a week one onboarding document that we have people run through. She ran through it in three days, so she seems highly motivated. She's got a very pleasant voice, right? So very calming.
Yes.
Right, so that's always really good. Now, the goals for us.
as SpiderNet is to make, so one challenge, and you've probably seen this too, when people start, the challenge is that we need our customers to know who she is. So even if she had every single answer there was, people will sidestep anything new.
Yes.
Mhm.
anybody new and then go to the people that they're used to, even if we have a ticket system and all this other stuff, right? So the key for my team is to make sure that she is constantly shadowing my team and that my team is constantly introducing her to all the people that she'll interface with.
and that my cyber folks aren't going too much into the weeds on cyber. I don't want her going deep into cyber. I want her concentrating on the level one cyber. Maybe that's a threat locker approval. Maybe it's, you know, something basic. That's where I want to be with that. So my directive to my team
is to focus on those things and get in front of these customers and make sure that they're making the introduction search so she is comfortable to make those calls in the future and to interface with these customers in the future, right? As far as some of our more enterprise customers, we have some...
some baseline tasks we'll probably introduce her to. The key, as we talked about when we started, is if we can take these level 1, level 1 plus, early level 2 tickets, if we can take them and free up resources internally so that we can get her good at those items.
then it's going to open up a lot of time for our level two, three. So that's a big deal for us, right? As far as where she's at now.
She's gotten through the training. Now a little bit of the ownership leans our way because now we have to get her out there. We have to do our job, right? And the longer we wait to get her out there, even if we're, like everything is shadowing still, right? It's only been a few days.
The longer it takes for us to shadow, the longer it takes for her to, the longer her ramp is, right? So we need to get her out there. We need to do it in a clear and concise way with our guys so that she can have the success she needs as quickly as she can, right? So that's my take.
As far as, you know, technical capability, I don't, I mean, I know what's on the resume. It seems like she's highly motivated. So that's really good. So that's my, Andrew, do you have anything anything to add based on based on the information that?
That that that I said, or or anything that you could cause Andrew has shadowed shadowed her I think a few times and and walked through the week one onboarding as well there too, so did you have any comments?
I was just going to say she's been doing really well. Seems very motivated, ready to jump into things. We just don't want to scare her away and toss her into the weeds already. But yeah, she seems motivated. She finished the week one onboarding and yeah, I'm trying to get Dan to do some more shadowing with her today so she can get more comfortable with the ticketing queue.
She seems to know how to pick them up. I want her to do some more test tickets, make sure she's good with entering the time, working out the time entries.
I think that's really it. She's been doing really well.
Thank you so much, Andrew. Talking to you the first time, so great to see you. And I appreciate all the quick feedback on that. What important, first of all, thank you for great feedback. And I think that sounds like a plan that Anthony just mentioned. So some takeaway for us as well. So we'll work internally with Sophie.
Yeah, you as well.
Time entries, I think that is going to be a critical part, what I heard. So, Gagan, whenever we are having a conversation with Sophie, we can just emphasize on that. She knows she's a seasoned player, so she knows the importance of time entries, bill label versus non-billabel. If you can just, you know, if you can just re-emphasize on that to just make sure that she understands it. Rest, thank you. Looks like you already have a plan.
The.
Andrew, that you're working with Sophie. Just let us know if wherever we could be of any help. I'm always available on Teams, me, Gagan, and Rick, in case if you have anything you need from us, just drop a message and we will definitely revert on that. That sounds like a good plan for me, so nothing else from my side.
Anything, anything you want to add? Anything else you want to add, Anthony?
Perfect.
I, I, I sort of get into what Gagan presents as far as his slides. I know we we were trying to, like, like with Sam, we were trying to get into the slides. It was it was very early on. I think it would be a good refresher, Gagan, if if you if you just sort of run through it.
Yeah.
Yep, please.
One more time, it'll be good for Andrew to see, and and it it helps us it helps us stay aligned. We may not have all the answers right now, we're not going to, but we're at least we have we have a sense of a vision of where we're headed right with the slide deck, so that's helpful.
Absolutely. Yeah, thank you.
Yep, thank you so much, Anthony. Yep.
Mm-hmm.
I hope you'll be able to see my screen now.
Yep.
Thank you. So we already covered these points. So currently, there are no lights, fortunately, and help required. So yeah, so the general help would be initial support from both side teams to Sophie from your side and our side. So this is going to be in my agenda. And
My focus.
Moving on to performance review, so governance, so we'll be conducting these weekly, then slowly, gradually, after a few weeks or maybe after a month, a month and a half, we'll move to, as feasible from both sides, we'll move.
move on to bi-weekly service calls. And then after a few months, maybe 90 days, 60 or 90 days, we can move on to monthly service calls if things are moving in place correctly.
And then every quarter we have a quarterly business review. So as we discussed previously, this is not only about the engineer, she's performing at SpiderNet Consulting, but this is from a business standpoint as well, how ITBD as whole, as business entity can support SpiderNet.
and anything that you foresee, or any kind of strategies, challenges that we can sit together, discuss together, and support each other in those scenarios.
Discuss highlights, lowlights, yeah. Propose continual improvements. So this is going to be our agenda. Always be, I would say. Any risk and provide mitigation as things, you know, come our way. So we'll take decision accordingly.
Anything from your end that we probably did not.
mentioned here that needs to be here.
Not yet.
Okay, thank you.
I'm skipping productivity slides as of now because she has not started working with SpiderNet as of now. So that, I mean, although you have seen the sample previously, so going forward from coming week onwards, we'll start to include that. And after this slide, I will show you the files that we're preparing eternally.
I think, Rick, this has already been discussed with Anthony. Are you coming? Have you booked your tickets already?
I probably won't. I'll probably pass on this one. We'll take a look at next year.
Okay.
All right, not an issue.
And Team GPS tool, I think you're already aware of this. I mean, you might not have taken demo for this tool yet. This is a homegrown tool. So whenever you have time, please do scan this QR code. Our team will be able to give you a demo, a complete demo about this tool. And you will find this useful. I'm sure it is useful. This is AI enabled.
Tool, and these are some of the features we have mentioned here. It helps in one-on-one group meetings, employee engagement activities, client management, performance management, rewards and recognition, strategic goals alignment, and everything. These are some of the features, but...
It has way more features. So when you have 30 minutes or more, you can scan this QR code and let our team know. They will give you a just glance of this tool, what challenges or what problems it can address, which you might be, might want to fix in your environment. Thank you.
These are some of the other tools that ITBD talks about, so I'll skip for now. But once our team will connect with you, they can give you more idea and glance over it. Rick, would you like to have you discussed? Yeah.
Oh yeah, just, just wanna, I just wanna check like Anthony, what are you guys right now or how your AI initiatives going on at SpiderNet?
Are we taking any?
Pre.
Right, we're all using Copilot pretty consistently on a day-to-day basis. So I'd say, I don't know, Andrew, I'd say probably maybe, I know with me, maybe 2 plus hours a day. I'm in it, a lot of our guys are utilizing it and leveraging it at a higher level.
Um, as far as uh, you know, running numbers for any kind of special projects, things, things of that sort.
So, it just it just the basic things like using the co-pilot and other AI tools that what's being followed right now, correct me right, right, Anthony.
Right, right, and and right, and the one the one thing that we would like to optimize in the next 12 months is to to to fortify the AI functionality that's going to be coming with our Kaseya in our in our ticketing with Autotask, so we have.
We have the AI functionality built into it. A lot of their stuff is in early release, but when it comes to queuing tickets based on the skill sets and the calendar and who has time as far as resources, those are all things that are
that are going to be leveraged by us in the future. They would especially help to sort of automate some baseline configurations as it relates to, you know, getting tickets closed out early on and assigned to the right people based on resource. So all those things are things we're going to focus on with the AI side.
My hope is that once we get Sophie,
You know, comfortable and and the Kaseya side catches up, we can we can start to build this out and and really sort of move faster as it relates to those functions in our auto task.
Got it. So that's what I want to understand. So right now it's pretty basic at SpiderNet. So I don't see like you guys, but you did mention what's your plan right now to do in next six months, right? Doing those automation workflows, auto triaging, all those parts. But there isn't any roadmap that you have, Anthony, on your side, right?
Yes.
And in terms of not just just having the workflows, the auto triaging part, having the agent set up like the digital dispatcher or a QA agent or a QBR agent, or getting yourself ready with the AI products to sell to the, you know, your partners and getting revenue generated from the AI thing, not just implementing AI in your site, right?
So, if you are fine.
We can have a discovery call doing a quick AI assessment with you, Anthony, and Andrew, having you guys on the call in our AI team and doing a quick assessment, then showing you the results where SpiderNet stands right now and what the roadmap looks like for them. What would be the quick...
things that we can do 1st and to achieve that roadmap. And then we can go from there, whatever looks best for you.
I'll take a plan.
Perfect. So let me just get some slots. Do you have some time this Friday?
I am going to say...
But I would like to probably get some traction with Sophie and make that the focus this week, but can we do sometime middle to end of next week? Actually, Andrew was on vacation that time. Yeah, how about the week of the week of...
OK.
Sure.
Sure, I'm.
Yeah, I'll be out next week.
Twenty-second.
Yeah.
Yeah, whatever works, Wednesday, Thursday, 24, 25, 26, whatever works best for you, Anthony and Andrew. I can.
How about Andrew 11 AM 24th Wednesday?
Yeah, that works.
Yeah, if you have that, let me know, guys, we can lock it in.
And Anthony, any other slot also you can give me like couple of slots so I can make sure our team has option to select one.
Sure. 11 o'clock on the 25th.
Okay, 24th, 25th, 11, right?
You can do 1 o'clock on the 24th, 1 o'clock on the 25th.
Perfect. That works. 11 and one that works. I can get that skip to it. No, thank you. Thank you, Andrew. That helps. Thanks, Anthony.
OK.
Yep.
What would you, Evan?
Thank you, let me unmute. Okay.
Just a moment, I need to find my slide.
Yep.
Andrew was asking about this. Just make sure you explain this because Andrew definitely helps with people shifting in and out of vacations and days and things like that and us specifically communicating what the schedule looks like for these optional holidays, choose fruit 2 from the list, those kinds of things.
So this is an important slide.
So, Andrea.
At ITBD, we provide 10 holidays to our employees. Eight are compulsory holidays. So these are showing on the left hand side. And for the remaining 2 holidays, which we call them optional holidays, because it's not that they cannot take, they must take those two holidays, but they have.
out of five options, they can choose two. So these are on the right hand side. So as of now, Diwali is the major one that she's considering to take. However, if the plan changes, you know, we'll let you know in advance. However, we have many, many months before that, October and November.
So, compulsory holidays and, you know, can be marked on your calendar. However, if you think there is any sort of business requirement, special business requirement coming on that day, and you want her attendance, her presence, you know, on specific dates, so please do let us know. We can make necessary arrangements and...
She can take complimentary off later on against that. Yeah, please.
Gagan, I got a question for you.
From for the optional holidays, is there is there a holiday in there?
Or like a holiday that like, like everybody just wants to take off over there. Like, is there a day?
Like, that's more popular than others.
Yeah.
About Christmas, yeah, so...
If I understood you.
Like Christmas is like a big deal for us. Like New Year's Day is a big deal for us. Like, you know, like, but is it different over there? Like, are any of these days like comparable to that? Like, are they like, oh my gosh, if I got this day off, it'd be the best day ever. Like that kind of day, right?
Right.
Yes.
Okay.
Okay. Absolutely. From, I would say for India's standpoint, Diwali, which is here on November 9th, this is the biggest festival in India. So, which most people do not want to miss. They like to, sometimes if they have, if they are not taking, let's say,
Big one, OK.
Okay.
frequent PTOs, they plan their PTOs for that specialty as well. So adjoining to Diwali. So I mean, we can make necessary adjustments as possible, but we may consider Diwali as the major one. So she will most likely take this.
Got it.
more than 90% of the chance. Okay.
That's fine.
Yeah, so apart from that, in summers, I would say many people, you know, choose to take Holi that you see in the mod, but that is already gone. We'll think of this next year now. So in summers, it's Holi, and in winters, it's Diwali. Okay.
So these are two major ones I can count on as of now.
So, what do they do? They they dance, they they they light candles, they they uh they sound stuff like what are they doing for Diwali?
Ohh.
That's really a good question. I will definitely send you more details on it. I mean, if I, you know, I'll definitely prepare something and share about Indian holidays. Yeah, so Diwali, it is, I would say it's sort of, it has, you know, many belief systems by different people. So mostly, majorly, it is a religious festival.
And so people celebrate when the deity, you know, came home. And so they light up their homes, you know, with different kind of lights and the firecrackers and, you know, wear new clothes, was a temple. Yeah.
All sort of activities, if...
Day 3, light oil lamps, is that like a cool day?
Oh yes, oil lamps, candles, even electric lights and everything. So.
Yeah.
What's the best day?
Uhh...
Is there a best day?
Best day.
The.
Is there a best day or are they all best days?
What?
Yeah.
So if you get a chance, you know, visit India during those days, you'll see, you know, in night will not look darker. You'll see light all around if you go to markets. So markets are completely lit up with beautiful, you know, colorful white lights, you know, throughout.
day and night. I mean, so they do not just take up those decorations till the month of January. So from October till November, December and January till Christmas, New Year, and most of these days, I mean, they cover up with those decorations. So it's a very different way of seeing India during those days.
So, thank you for touching upon. I'll show you, you know, a few things, so you know, which will give you more glance at it.
That's.
So that's day four, November 9th.
November 9th got Gaurav done, Puja.
Yes.
Uhh...
That is, that will be a whole week of celebration, Anthony, if I give you more details on that, starting with Diwali, then we have Maya Doj Gaurav, and so it's like a week of festival for Hindu community, you know, where, so this is, this is more like a combination of Thanksgiving and Christmas for us.
Oh.
S.
OK.
Got it.
You know, where, where whole family come together for dinner, they are, they are, you know, kids, they are, you know, they're cracking fires and everything over there, and you know, they're celebrating the day together.
Okay.
S.
Yeah.
OK.
Got it.
Yep.
I'll, you know, Gagan is definitely going to share some pics, some videos with you. How do we celebrate that? It's a day of new beginning, new clothes, new house, everything.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Yeah, as this is called, yeah, this is called Festival of Joy, if I can summarize that for you.
India, like, yeah.
Got it.
Yep.
And India is the country of festivals. So, you know, in every different region, we have different celebration, different festivals, region-wise as well, if not nationwide. So there are a few festivals that the entire nation, you know, celebrates, but there are many which different regions celebrate. So, yeah, if you'll see our calendar,
It is full of, especially winter season is full of festivals. Okay. So in the interest of time, you know, I'll just keep that for the separate discussion and we'll share some more insight on that. So moving on really quickly to way forward. Excuse me.
So as we already know that our, because this is Sophie's initial phase with SpiderNet, so our main focus would be to let her successfully complete her initial onboarding and begin to take over tasks, you know, for which she has hired and start to add value.
by looking at, by meeting her productivity targets on a daily and weekly basis and monthly basis, so on. And for my for my part, at my end and Michelle's for service delivery end, we do organize team collaboration activities, wherein we plan some dine-out activities, lunches, dinner.
So their team always feel like they're working with not just professional, family, who always need some numbers to be completed. So they want us to feel like family.
This is it. And let me unshare my screen and share some more really quick. I mean, I'll just take a few more minutes. We have two or three more minutes. Okay, I'll just wrap it up really quick. Thank you.
Follow me.
Yeah.
I hope my file is visible to everyone.
Yes, I can see it.
Thank you. So, Andrew and Anthony, so this is a 30, 60, 90 days plan by which we closely monitor what she has been accomplishing at the moment and what is on her way going forward in following days.
or following weeks or how she's going to complete in next 60 or 90 days. So so far, I mean, it has many fields, but it can be altered as per your preference and your requirements. So as of now, this is the initial phase I'll just quickly touch upon.
With my, you know, quick rate of speech, I'm sorry, because of the time, so yeah, so we have already, you know, conducted a call and she's introduced with the team, so this part is done. Employee handbook has been shared with her, so...
This is not closed yet. This is in progress. So I mean, because we still need to discuss a PTO plan and the other activities with Sophie that, you know, how she can take plan her PTOs, vacation, take holidays and everything. So I'll be discussing with her today. Okay. Which is why this is in progress at the moment.
Her phone system, I think she'll be using Teams for client communication. So that's been done. So I've marked this completed. System informed setup is done. Set up access to domain, yeah, her 365 Teams access has been granted to her. First day activity has been completed, most part is completed. So the one that is not completed is explained roles.
responsibility. I think she is, I mean, this is an ongoing activity, so she understands the tools that have been provided access with, but going forward, what all tasks, what all call drivers, what all boards should be managing, what all tasks she'll be responsible for, I think.
We need to just go a little more in depth into that. So this is from in my part as well. So I'll be discussing with you separately on that. So whatever your plan is for the first week, second week, and so on, so I can discuss the same with Sophie. Or your team can discuss directly with Sophie.
So.
Yeah, first day or week, I tend ready for the first week, it has been shared again with Sophie already. So, going forward from second day to day 10, go over Partner client Partner client details. So, she said that has been done, so she has been shared with some of the details. So, begin training chart, important process system tools.
This is in progress. I should mark it in progress.
So business model that's been done, communication short term and long term and everything, identify any training needs. So about this training needs and everything, you know, I have a separate document which is, which we call CDG. I'll share that with you. So Anthony, I will share this document with you.
Whatever you think is not relevant that those items can be removed or you think there is something this document is missing so those can be added in here so that we both are on the same page. Okay.
Sounds good.
So just wanted to touch upon this. If you have any question on this as of now, please do let us know.
Got it.
Okay, I'm sharing my screen and quickly sharing the other document, Vishal. I'm sorry if you have some time constraints at the moment.
You're good.
I just need a few minutes.
All yours? I mean, we are already like 5 minutes past for the scheduled time, but give entrance availability. Thank you so much. Yeah, yeah.
We're good, dogging. I'm loving.
Yeah.
I'm loving it, just keep rocking it.
Thank you, Anthony. I appreciate your cooperation, and...
Garet.
All right, so...
This is a career development plan for Sophie. So this is a very detailed oriented sheet. I'm sure you must have seen this when Sam was onboarded. So that was as per his skill set, what he already knew, and as per your requirements, what he needs to do.
understand which skill sets he needs to improve. So this is what it is defining. So PSA tools, this is a word, so yellow or...
The items which Sophie Sophie already knows, she understands, and I think previously you also marked this is immediate, so ConnectWise manage, she understands, ConnectWise connect, but I I know you're managing, you have auto task, OK?
So I think anything that she is marking down, so she'll be needing a refresher on those things. So we can collaborate and work on this together. If you have any documentation ready with you, which can be provided with Sophie, so she can go through that document.
Right.
or training module and if in case that is not available, do let us know and we can make internal arrangements at our end and we can get it scaled with those things.
So I'll just quickly touch upon for RMM. She already knows ConnectWise Azio, Casia, Ninja RMM. DATO is something she needs attention on. So she needs a refresher on data. I believe in your environment, data is primary.
Uh-huh.
You use data BCDR and everything, data RMM as well, so.
Right.
When it comes to RMM, do you use only data RMM or screen type and other tools as well?
That will RMM, and I know Andrew has showed her how to move around within it. Andrew, what did? How did you feel once when she when she was able to sort of connect the dots?
Mhm.
I just...
Yeah, I told her to take it slow because there's a lot of information in RMM, like all the different sites, computers, everything about each computer. So I told her to just poke around in there. You can see all the different clients. She can customize the columns. But yeah, I just wanted to get comfortable seeing all the different data and where it is on the different pages.
All right, thank you. In reporting, she understands bright gauge.
Service, service, she understands ConnectWise, crew who in operating system, she understands Active Directory, Mac OS operating systems, Microsoft servers from 2012 to 2022, Windows environment operating systems from Windows 8.
to Windows 11, she understands PowerShell. Virtualization, she does not have much hands-on, which is why she is not feeling confident at the moment. But if this is significant in your environment, I see previously you did Mark long-term, but this is not an immediate goal.
But if you think that is any of these things, which is marking no, if that is something she needs to learn on, please do let us know. We can initiate and start training immediately so that she can be.
Hyper-V is huge. It's pretty much everywhere and every single customer.
Okay, so it should have mic soon. She must learn it immediately or soon.
So that's VMware.
Not on VMware, on Hyper-V.
Yeah, VMware not, we don't have any VMware, so it's all Hyper-V.
Okay, hyperweek, okay.
Yeah.
Immediate, should I say?
I would say immediate, yeah.
Okay, thank you.
For VOIPs, you understand 3 CX, Ayra, Ring Central, Aid by Nextiva.
So this is something basic, email hosting, Gmail, Intermedia, Office 365, Google Workspace, she understands. These are the other ones. I mean, if you think these are important in your environment, App River, AppTix, Rackspace. Okay, thank you.
Yeah, none of that, no, that's all she's fine there, as far as backup, uh, the Dadu.
The data, that's a that's an immediate.
Okay.
All right, thank you.
And then on fire on firewalls, SonicWall, that would be an immediate.
Mhm.
Okay, thank you.
and wireless, I would say. Go ahead.
Just one moment, sorry. Do you want it to be level one at least on this or?
Level one's fine.
Okay, thank you.
I mean, whatever you would put, SSL VPN, walkthrough troubleshooting, that kind of stuff, I mean, I don't think we need to get into level 2 mid or level 2 plus on firewalls right now anyway.
Mhm.
Okay, sure. Okay.
And AP is Access Point. She understands Aruba at the moment, but there are many. What do your clients use the most?
open mesh and a little bit of ruckus.
Darryl.
Okay.
So, there's the Dattos, yeah, and then, and then Ruckus.
You know, is it is it critical that you know Ruckus?
No, but an L1 on Ruckus would be nice.
Okay.
Now, one on data open mesh, that would be nice.
Yeah, so, okay, okay, I got it. Thank you.
None of the other ones we use.
So, let's see, add a weapon mesh rock, yeah.
Network switches.
Then we have...
I think that would be too advanced for her, but do let us know. I mean, she needs to touch upon any of these network switches. Okay. For hardware, yeah, I think that dinner usually need to work on hardware because she's not an on-site engineer, but she does know.
Uh...
Yeah.
Nah, I'm fine. Nah, that's fine.
Bell.
Yep.
I mean...
If you see about others, yeah, she she has a hands-on experience on Acer, SS, Dell, HP, IBM, Lenovo. These are the major ones that most client uses. SAN, if we if we need something.
Yeah, she's good.
Yeah.
Or, I'll be good.
We don't use any of those.
Okay.
Yeah.
Antivirus, so she understands Windows Defender, McAfee, Sophos, Sentinel One, Huntress, Threat Locker. There are many other, if you think.
M.
Yeah, so the key there is going to be a threat locker in addition to Dadu EDR.
Yeah, Threadlocker is, she knows already, an antivirus.
Yeah.
Reset.
Right, and then, yeah, data EDR.
Yeah, I need to add that.
Just say ADR or whatever you want to call it.
I think they call it data EDR, don't they, Andrew?
Yeah.
The data VDR is built off of like Windows Defender. There's like a whole separate portal for it.
and a anti-spyler.
Anky, ohh, that's, that's, that's, that wouldn't be anti-spyware. Yeah, I'd be, I guess, for anti-spyware, was that DNS filtering? We're using ThreatLocker for that, for anti, I guess, right? When you call it that, if you talk about DNS, DNS filtering, what not.
Yeah.
Yes, I think.
Email filtering.
Yeah.
Be Threat Locker.
Web control.
Yeah, web control. And then email filtering is an application that Kaseya recently purchased, which is called Inky, I-N-K-Y.
But.
Okay.
We have Mimecast, but we're phasing out of Mimecast. Well, that's so Inky is more of an email filtering, just so you know.
So, okay.
Yeah, it's more it's more of an email filter.
You're saying a web filter as well, something?
So that, so you'll probably just want to take your Kase inky that you put in spyware, take that out and place it in the email filtering section.
Kour.
Sure.
Yeah.
It was right underneath.
Right underneath where you were at.
Oh yeah, sure. Right. Thank you.
Yeah, there you go, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's...
It's not it's not as complex as something like a like a Mimecast, although we still we we do we you might wanna put Mimecast in there as well for email filtering. It's it's something that we still have, and it's gonna take a few months, or if not the year, to to to migrate away from.
Mhm.
Okay, sure.
Yeah.
And I think Mike has something she understands already. Okay. Thank you.
All in backup, she understands Acronis, but I think you use data more, right?
Yep.
What else?
That's good enough. There, um, Dubey, this is, yeah, it's all bad, yeah.
Okay.
BCD or Altadero.
Okay, thank you.
UPS, CyberPower, and APC, Eaton, all three of those. APC is Eaton, right?
Are they safe? Let me know.
Is it APC?
Yeah.
Is that what you use? OK.
Yeah, and then some cyber fire, but...
Kour.
Same flavor.
Yeah.
Okay, she is OneDrive, SharePoint.
That's good.
Um...
As far as you have no before for DNS filtering, I would say for phishing and training simulation, I don't know if that's in that list somewhere. That would be a bullfish with Kaseya.
Yeah.
But.
We used Nova 4, but we're phasing out of that.
Is a bullfish.
Yeah, yeah.
The Casea product.
Okay, sure.
Uh, vendor license management, she probably won't need to touch, but it's it's an X. She probably won't, she probably won't touch that.
She won't.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right, thank you. So...
Did you?
Did you want to just flip back to the top few? Because I feel like we almost pretty much ran through this whole thing. PSA, so PSA we already know is auto task, right? So PSA is auto task. That's the key one for us.
Mmh.
Mm.
Yeah.
Okay, and then we have for RMM, it's going to be data.
That's our key.
You don't need ConnectWise Manish, right?
Yeah.
OK.
We don't need Halo.
But I don't know if that's just what she knows or whatnot. We don't need that. And then for RMM, yeah, if you want to clear that one out. And so for RMM, the only one that she'll touch is that RMM.
Yeah.
Mhm.
For reporting, it's going to be auto-task, which she probably will barely touch that, but we don't use bright gauge.
We don't use any of the other ones, so...
Okay.
So for reporting auto task, how quickly do you need that? Immediate or soon?
Not, not quick, no, I would say, I would say whenever, yeah, yeah, and then service survey, she, she, we use crew, none of the other ones we use.
Okay.
Long term? Okay, long term for now. All right.
You ask who?
Yeah.
Okay.
And really, I mean, what's involved there, just sometimes our people will say, hey, listen, if I did well on this ticket, can you rate me? That's about the extent of people getting at a crew other than buying gift cards and rewards based on their points, right? So as far as operating systems, that looks fine. Virtualization, you already know.
Mhm.
VoIP systems, it seems like she knows so many, it doesn't really matter. And Teams is like a throw in. So that's really a non-issue. Posted email, the only thing she's going to touch is Office 365. She'll touch, she'll barely touch Google Workspace.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Okay.
Maybe.
3% of the time she'll touch Google Workspace. The rest, the 97% of the time it's all Office 365.
Mhm.
Okay.
Nothing else in that list.
Cloud servers, Azure, maybe.
We have AWS, but you know, I don't know if we'd.
Should we say that Andrew is AWS in their cloud servers, Amazon Web?
I don't think she'll really need anything with AWS. I mean, we have one customer that uses it, but...
Yeah, hey.
Yeah, back on up. Nah, you're good. I think, I think you're good.
Gagan.
Great, thank you. So, Andrew and Anthony, I'll share this with you. You can review anything, you know, that you think, you know, needs to be here, which she needs to, you know, upskill herself, and those documentations are available with you. Let us know if there's something you want ITBD to do.
Yeah.
train her on, you know, we'll take on that task. Okay.
All right, thank you.
So that was coming off from my end. Vishal, anything from your end before we wrap it up, before I go to Anthony and Andrew.
No, thank you so much for taking care of this call, Gagan. You presented in a detail and I loved it. Thank you so much for doing that. Nothing else from my side. I'm good. Thank you.
Thank you, Vishal, Anthony, uh, Anthony from your end.
No, I appreciate you running through that. Thanks for the check-in and all good.
Everything good on my end. I like the document. I got a screenshot, but if you could share some more of that, that'd be great just so we can keep on track with our items.
Great.
Sure, thank you. Yeah, this is evolution, so we continuously make changes and you know, upgradation on these documentation and everything. So, as we as we'll move along, if there are any more changes, upgradations in our services and everything, we'll continuously share those things and details with you, so that...
I mean, we are always on the same page in terms of the progress that we're making and the tracking and everything. Okay.
Awesome.
All right, so thank you team for joining in and spending extra time on this call and going forward. I mean, for now onwards, you know, weekly basis as well. You know, anyhow, we'll be having this connect. So one more thing, Anthony, Wednesday,
Sounds good.
you know, 2 P.m. sometime, you know, may have clash, you know, bi-weekly basis with my other calls. Does this time suit you always?
Most of the times, or some of the time.
This time, this time can work, yeah, this is for, so what, what is, geez, today's Monster, yeah, this, yeah, that's that works.
All right, that's great.
That's great. So we'll keep 11 A.m. at this time for our weekly call going forward. Okay.
Awesome.
All right, thank you. If there are any changes, we'll discuss prior to getting on the call. Thank you very much. All right, Team, thank you very much for joining in, and we'll connect again with some more positive updates very soon. Thank you. Thank you. Bye everyone.
Thank you. Thanks, guys.
Yep, thank you very much.
Thea.
See it.